m
[Musique]
bonne année bonne santé beaucoup de
bonheur beaucoup de joie à tous je vous
souhaite le meilleur pour 2018 ça y est
on y est 2018 l'année 2010 est pour moi
en tout cas a été une excellente année
je sais pas pour vous est-ce que tout
s'est bien passé est ce que vous avez eu
des réussites personnelles la santé
l'amour la joie
vous savez le paquet du bonheur qu'on
soit tous les ans la même année dites
moi ça s'est bien passé pour vous un
commentaire
et dites moi ce que vous attendez pour
2018 de mon côté début de set a été
quand même une excellente année un peu
particulière un peu bizarre parce que
c'est en réalité la première fois que je
lançais sur youtube et que je crée cette
chaîne je les crée fin 2016 aux
alentours du 16 décembre 2016 mais début
2010 est c'était vraiment les tout
débuts les prémices on a commencé à 17
abonnés aujourd'hui on est plus de 13000
on a commencé à pas grand-chose en vue
aujourd'hui on a passé les 1 million 700
mille vue chien vraiment à vous
remercier tous tous tous que vous soyez
abonné pas abonnés que vous regardiez
occasionnellement régulièrement que vous
regardiez toutes les vidéos que vous
soyez le premier à commenter ou alors
vous commentiez jamais le dernier
peu importe je tenais tout ça vous
remercier tout particulièrement parce
que ça me fait chaud au coeur ça me fait
énormément plaisir et pour 2018
on va avoir énormément sans prise il ya
plein de choses qui vont arriver et
vraiment je pense qu'on va s'éclater
ensemble avant d'attaquer les fameuses
bonnes résolutions qu'on a en chaque
début d'année et qu'en règle générale on
tient pas et justement je vais casser un
peu le truc parce que j'ai effectivement
avoir des bonnes résolutions pour 2018
et cette fois ci je vais vraiment les
tenir donc avant de vous donner tout de
suite les bonnes résolutions en faire
une petite rétrospective de l'année 2010
est en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
par rapport à la chaîne youtube par
rapport aux vidéos et on va regarder ça
tout de suite ensemble alors 2007 a été
une année quand même particulièrement
riche
il ya eu énormément de choses je prends
moov up mon ordi que je propose c'est de
regarder un petit peu les vidéos que
j'ai tourné regardez un peu les
différents moments les moments qui ont
compté par rapport à soupe ont été un
vrai bide je vais pas vous mentir un
quand j'ai commencé tout au début
c'était fondamentalement pas gg alors je
dis pas qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'apothéose
est que c'est la finalité mais en tout
cas je suis un peu plus content de du
format aujourd'hui et on va aller encore
plus loin en 2000
vite mais ça on en parlera tout à
l'heure alors voir un peu ce que t'es
sympa cette année en 2017
au début j'ai voulu voir les formats qui
me plaisait c'est à dire faire du blog
parler de choses assez personnelle mais
sans que ça intéresse beaucoup de monde
parce que franchement on va le dire
c'était pas très intéressant je me
présente je suis monsieur bruges puis
youtube heures tu veux je me présente
monsieur de ruches sur des vidéos partir
d'aujourd'hui une vidéo par jour
l'idée c'est de s'amuser haïti c'est une
vidéo qui m'a bien plu c'était une vidéo
que j'ai publié 9 janvier 9 janvier
l'année dernière un avis d eau quand je
suis parti au nigeria en 2003 ça c'était
une expérience de dengue et je suis
super content de cette vidéo c'est
vraiment la première vidéo sérieuse où
je partage une expérience où je partage
quelque chose et c'était un souvenir
souvenir de dingue
et
aloès et yen
arrigoni et malanje nord alors dans les
vidéos bon il ya eu des choses qui n'ont
pas trop marché au début c'était
vraiment généraliste et de l'humour
c'est ce qui me faisait marrer jeu sorti
une vidéo peut-on coucher avec sa
cousine
il ya quand même 5775 vue bon il faut
croire qu'il ya beaucoup d' il ya
beaucoup de restes garde la pêche une
vidéo que j'avais fait à c'était 22
décembre 2016 mais sur le groupe
facebook garde la pêche
quasiment trente mille vue hockey dès
qu'on parle un peu de seins et fesses
tout de suite là il ya du monde 2017 a
été vraiment marqué au début en tout cas
par une vidéo qui va entre guillemets
montré la voie qui m'a fait aller vers
une de mes passions à la itech et cette
vidéo temps et je voulais retrouver
c'est une vidéo qui publie le 14 février
est assez marrante 14 février j'avais
même pas fait gaffe pour la saint
valentin c'est comme quoi un rumeurs
iphone 8 les dernières rumeurs sur
l'iphone 8 dévoilé salut à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de l'iphone
vite on l'appelle aussi l'iphone os x je
m'intéresse c'est vraiment un style fun
8 me demande à quoi il allait ressembler
et du coup bon bah j'en ai fait une
vidéo cette vidéo aujourd'hui elle à 337
1696 vue c'est dingue 1120 commentaires
3239 poussent vers le haut 9 8 109 vers
le bas et ouais vidéo de dengue qui a
permis à la chaîne de grossir
pourquoi pas tenter quelque chose qui
nous plaît là il ya du monde de l'autre
côté et ça c'était vraiment un truc un
truc de dingue
alors il ya eu des vidéos qui ont signe
pas mal marché qui m'ont vraiment
conforté dans le fait que tout ce que tu
es technologies
et un truc génial pour moi j'adore ça la
nintendo switch pareil le 8 février
c'est un petit peu avant 43000 vue
[Musique]
alors ça reviendra que la tech les
astuces sur ce match at juste avant le 3
février 13 mai du bon après j'ai fait
des gros trucs pas très intéressant
plutôt mal fichu mais c'est pas grave je
me suis vraiment éclaté en essayant
plein de choses différentes et je crois
que c'est le plus important
le plus important ce que je vais retenir
tout ça c'est le partage dès que vous
aimez quelque chose vous le partagez
vous faites une vidéo elle vaut ce
qu'elle vaut 1 c'est pas grave on peut
se planter faire l'étude pas terrible
c'était vraiment pas génial
une fois de plus je dis pas que ce que
je peux aujourd'hui est fantastique mais
on a mais j'ai progressé et c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est de se rend compte
de la progression et du chemin qui a été
fait ensuite l'autre vidéo qui a
vraiment cartonné et qui a été pour moi
aussi un révélateur sur les choses à
faire et la manière dont les faire c'est
la vidéo du hellfest 2017
[Musique]
égaler puis surtout il ya vait aerosmith
qui passaient et aerosmith est un groupe
que j'adore depuis que je suis gamin
j'allais vraiment d'aller le voir
je m'intéresse au rock le métal ça
m'intéresse aussi alors c'est moi mon
truc mais ça m'intéressait vraiment
j'avais vraiment envie découvert ce
festival
du coup on est partis au hellfest avec
un avec un pote et c'était un truc de
dingue et la vidéo avec les folles la
vidéo 120 2193 vu des pousses des
commentaires alors je me suis fait
énormément trachée mais c'était une
vidéo vous moment où on partage quelque
chose qu'on aime partager vraiment
quelque chose qui a été complètement
dingue le ffs ça a été un truc truc un
truc qui piquent d'ailleurs cette année
on y retourne et a contrario j'ai fait
une vidéo qui a moins bien plus j'ai
fait une vidéo j'ai répondu un peu à
tous les messages de haine entre
guillemets où je me suis fait des boîtes
et par rapport à cette vidéo du hellfest
parce que il ya quand même un vrai
clivage chez les métalleux il ya ceux
qui sont pour une ouverture en faisant
même si vous n'aimez pas le métal venez
nous rejoindre en faire un truc de
dingue
il ya ceux qui au contraire vise non
c'est un truc pour les initiés site est
pas initiés c'est vraiment pas quelque
chose que tu aimes tu n'as pas ta place
donc ne vient pas donc j'étais en plein
milieu de la polémique ma vidéo été
relayée par le hellfest d'ailleurs merci
à la prod du hellfest d'avoir relayé
sans votre page facebook la vidéo
donc j'ai une vidéo qui ont complètement
cartonné j'ai fait une réponse à ces
messages là je regrette un peu ça sert
mais un peu à rien ça nourrit la
polémique
on l'a quand même fait dévisser mais
moins que sa porte est pas grand chose
mais c'est pas grave c'est comme ça
qu'on sort son expérience et qu'on se
rend compte c'est les choses moins
intéressantes au mieux non donc non pas
de regrets là dessus j'ai eu une chiée
excusez moi du terme et une chip
commentaires in qu'est ce que tu fous là
c'est quoi ces hipster qu'est ce qu'il
fout clac dégagez vous n'avez pas votre
place
j'ai été surpris pourquoi alors pour
plusieurs raisons ensuite cette année
d'une clause cool en partenariat avec
lenovo j'ai testé la lie aux gays book
j'ai pu faire pas mal de choses et
surtout l'autre truc qui m'a vraiment
passionné c'est
le fait d'aller à l'ifa à berlin et de
pouvoir rencontrer toutes ces sociétés
qui créent la itech et de pouvoir
partager ces moments là on est en
contact direct et de pouvoir partager
avec vous donc ça j'ai trouvé ça juste
extraordinaire les chemins terme parce
que vos salons etc etc on peut trouver
au mois de septembre
lifar durant quelques jours va y avoir
tous les meilleurs produits de la high
tech à découvrir donc ça c'était
vraiment quelque chose de super
intéressant et qui m'a permis de me
rendre compte que et la high tech c'est
bien d'en parler dans son local dans son
studio mais qu'il faut en sortir qu il
faut aller plus loin qu'il faut aller
dehors pour partager avec vous et pour
être vraiment au coeur de ce qui se
passe
être sur le terrain et couvrent le
terrain donc ça j'ai trouvé ça génial
complètement dingue
alors il ya autre chose cette année qui
m'a aussi beaucoup plus cg fin des hors
séries je sais pas si vous avez suivi
cet été j'ai commencé un hors série sur
la stratégie youtube
j'ai commencé le 17 juillet donc j'ai
fait une vidéo qui s'appelle 10 astuces
pour créer une chaîne youtube de a à z
et bien des petites sur youtube vous
venez de créer votre chaîne youtube
voulais avoir plus d'abonnés avoir plus
de vue mais c'est extrêmement difficile
il ya une très grosse concurrence et
pour le sens votre chaîne youtube ne
décolle pas dans cette vidéo je vous
donnais 10 astuces indispensables pour
créer sa chaîne youtube les bases
fondamentales que tout youtuber doit
connaître pour gagner des vues et des
abonnés l'idée de cette vidéo et de
toutes ces séries que j'ai fait toute
cette série que j'ai fait c'était
vraiment de d'apporter mon mon sentiment
et mes conseils par rapport au peu
l'expérience que j'ai pour progresser
sur youtube parce que comme je vous le
disais sur youtube en quelques mois j'ai
réussi quand même à progresser à me
rends compte un peu de ce qui marche et
ce qui marchait pas et comment il
fallait faire les choses et quelles
étaient les erreurs et quelles étaient
les bonnes méthodes et les bonnes
techniques à mettre en place
donc j'avais cette ce hors série et ça
plutôt pas trop mal fonctionné et
surtout ce qui était passionnant parce
que même si pas des vidéos qui cumulent
des milliers
vues sont quand même des vidéos où je me
suis rendu compte qu'il ya énormément de
créateurs qui étaient en demande et
qu'ils avaient vraiment besoin de
conseils pour progresser et qui
cherchait vraiment savoir comment faire
pour gagner des mots clés pour trouver
les bons mots clés pour gagner des vues
sur youtube
et ça ça m'a donné des bonnes idées et
justement on va en parler tout à l'heure
donc voilà un peu sur cette
rétrospective un petit peu courte de 2
cette année il ya eu tout ça et sur la
fin de l'année il ya eu aussi une
rencontre de dingue notre rencontre qui
était complètement dingue que j'ai fait
à berlin à l'ifa j'ai rencontré business
france la french tech après le texte
c'est là la mission économique de l'état
français qui regroupe toutes les
entreprises françaises qui travaillent
dans la grecque et énormément de
créateurs français de jeunes startups
innovantes autour de l'high tech et qui
ont des produits qui vont peut-être
changer votre votre quotidien demain ça
c'est vraiment un échange super fort et
j'ai été très heureux de pouvoir les
rencontrer d'ailleurs j'ai créé une
rubrique tech médine france vous pouvez
trouver là pour rendre hommage et pour
présenter toutes ces jeunes startups
parce que sur youtube
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas grand monde qui
en parle et c'est vraiment dommage
toutes les semaines je publie des vidéos
take made in france est souvent
rencontré les créateurs c'est vraiment
des gens qui sont inspirés ces des
passionnés et des histoires magnifiques
à chaque fois toutes ces rencontres
m'ont vraiment donné l'idée globale de
ce que devait être ma chaîne youtube et
se dire qu elle devait aller donc en
réalité tout chemin que j'ai parcouru en
2017 du début avec mes vidéos de blogs
assez pourrie jusqu'à mon cheminement en
fin d'année eh bien j'ai compris j'ai
compris comment il fallait que ça marche
ce que vous attendiez aussi ce qui vous
plaisait les sujets auxquels vous
réagissiez qui vous plaisait parce que
avant tout moi je partage ce qui
m'intéresse mais ce qui me plaît c'est
l'interaction avec vous c'est qu'on
puisse échanger
vous me dites ouais ça non forêt lien
c'est pas terrible ça ça me plait pas
qu'un j'ai une question à se poser
qu'est ce que tu penses de ça le fait de
pouvoir rencontrer les créateurs donc au
final on a une espèce de relation
moi je vais à la rencontre de
l'high-tech je vais rencontrer les
créateurs vous vous êtes là c'est papa
si vous n'êtes pas en train de regarder
les vidéos le puits ed m'aide pas aimé
peu importe mais surtout il ya une vraie
interaction
il ya des questionnements est ce que
j'aimerais bien aussi en 2018 c'est que
ce soit encore plus loin qu'on aille
encore plus loin
vous me disiez davantage ça j'aime ça
j'aime pas tiens j'ai envie de ce type
de vidéos est ce que tu pourrais faire
ça comme ça est-ce que
tu pourrais aller voir cette société là
est ce que tu peux parler de ce sujet
car ce qui m'intéresse
j'ai une question et ça c'est vraiment
génial et ça nous emmène tout ça aux
bonnes résolutions pour 2018
alors côté bonnes résolutions j'ai pris
de bonnes résolutions
alors c'est pas une résolution c'est un
peu un aparté l'idée c'est effectivement
d'aller plus loin dans la chaîne youtube
de faire plus de choses vous apporter
encore plus de contenu de contenus de
qualité et pour ça je vais vraiment
travailler davantage le storytelling
travailler encore plus les images j'ai
une nouvelle caméra que j'ai acheté il
ya pas longtemps pour aller encore plus
loin
capter les instants est allé plus vite
tout ça je vais le faire pour vraiment
partager avec vous ma passion de l'high
tech et ma passion du partage et des
découvertes en règle générale et pour ça
j'ai pris de bonnes résolutions
la première c'est une bonne résolution
et un objectif surtout en un an je vous
dis on n'est pas un peu plus de 1
million 700 mille vue sur cette chaîne
est plus de 13000 abonnés à la fin de
l'année 2018
ma bonne résolution mon objectif c'est
qu'on ait atteint les 100 mille abonnés
alors ça peut paraître un peu dingue
comme ça parce qu'effectivement 1 100
milles ça se fait pas en un claquement
de doigts il faut beaucoup de temps mais
très clairement à cent mille abonnés au
31 décembre 2018 on pourra dire que le
pari est gagné et j'espère que vous
allez être là vous allez de fidèles et
vous allez vous allez soutenir toute
l'année et me dire ce que vous en pensez
ça c'est bien c'est pas bien améliore ça
tu peux faire ce que tu peux faire ça
parce que ce que je fais moi je veux le
partager avec vous donc première bonne
résolution
les cent mille à la fin de l'année donc
ça veut dire améliorer la qualité aller
plus loin faire plus de choses plus
bouger se déplacer aller sur des salons
aller à la rencontre
donc ça c'est un package de bonnes
résolutions avec un objectif final fin
de mes dix huit cent mille abonnés et on
va commencer dans quelques jours
le 5 janvier je pars et ont fait un
grand périple parce que je vais à las
vegas aux crs pour vous parler de la
high tech du meilleur de la itech alors
il y aura plein de surprises je vais
passer par new york j'ai passé un jour
et demi à new york
je vais faire plein de vidéos
différentes mais tous sans mort
apparemment ça c'est la première bonne
résolution
la deuxième bonne résolution et concerne
le hors série que j'ai dès cet été comme
je vous disais c'est déjà j'ai fait des
vidéos où je parlais de stratégie
youtube
je donnais des conseils je partager mon
expérience les compétences que j'ai
acquise
je les partager avec vous parce que je
pense qu'il faut pas être radin faut pas
être égoïste
de toute façon il ya un truc qui est
très clair c'est qu'aujourd'hui youtube
c'est le média numéro un devant la télé
la vidéo streaming la vidéo vod sur
internet c'est vraiment aujourd'hui ce
qui est le plus regardé ce qui intéresse
le plus
parce que vous n'êtes pas tributaire de
votre télé vous n'êtes pas telle heure
devant tel programme
ça a complètement changé aujourd'hui
c'est vous qui décidez ce que vous
regardez comme un temps de le regarder
et ça c'est super intéressant donc
justement ça nous emmène à cette bonne
résolution c'est-à-dire créer une chaîne
youtube spécialement dédié aux créateurs
qui débutent et qui ont besoin de
conseils et qui ont besoin d'astuces
donc c'est vraiment ce que je suis en
train de faire c'est ce que je veux
faire avec vous pour aller plus loin
pour vous aider vous permettre d'avoir
les bonnes astuces cette chaîne vous
avez le lien en haut ici vous avez le
lien dans la description si vous êtes
youtuber si vous voulez progresser si
vous voulez des astuces et des conseils
je vous invite à vous abonner alors non
par les ja science infuse mais j'ai
acquis une petite expérience une petite
expertise qui est la mienne et au fur et
à mesure de mon parcours sur youtube
je partage ce qui marche ce qui marche
pas et ça c'est ce qui est intéressant
parce que toute façon ce qui compte sur
youtube c'est le partage
plus il ya de monde sur youtube plus on
est nombreux et plus il ya de réussite
dans tous les domaines et plus les
youtuber seront heureux parce qu'on va
tous les uns les autres avec nos
réussites personnelles tirées la machine
vers le haut et nous tirer tous les
horizons vers le haut donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai créé cette chaîne pour vous
permettre d'aller plus loin pour
partager ça avec vous et si ça vous
intéresse je vous invite à aller vous
abonner on va faire des évaluations de
chaînes en direct donc on fera des live
et vous pourrez poser toutes vos
questions sur ce qui marche qui marche
pas il y aura plein de vidéos il ya déjà
des vidéos à rennes aujourd'hui enfin
voilà donc ya tout un tas de choses je
vous invite à vous abonner pour aller
voir ça parce que ça s'arrête aussi
super intéressant voilà un petit peu on
en est aujourd'hui
j'espère que ces bonnes raisons
un groupe l'aise en tout cas sont les
médias sont très personnelles dites moi
vous quelles sont les autres vous
marquez tout ça en commentaires dont on
dit qu'elles sont vos résolutions
est-ce que vous en avez pris la plupart
du temps y qui en prennent plus parce
qu'ils se disent bon ça sert à rien j'ai
pris des bonnes résolutions faire
attention pour arrêter de fumer moins
manger bien venir est plus gentil et un
méchant mais la plupart du temps réalité
parce ne s'y tient les miennes je peux
vous assurer que je m'y tenir
je compte sur vous pour être présent
aussi marqué moi vos résolutions en
commentaires si vous en avez je vous
invite à mener c'est des jolies pousse à
vous abonner
parce qu'on appareils toujours plus de
découvertes vérité qui est plein de
choses innovantes
je vous remercie énormément d'être là
merci merci merci je vous aime vous êtes
des amours rester sage
restez connectés et on se dit à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]